[MUSIC PLAYING]
GABY WOOD: I'm very pleased to
reintroduce you to Andy, who--
well, you don't
need more details--
but is a great friend of
mine, I'm very proud to say.
He writes about all manner of
things, great essays and books,
indeed, about missing persons,
about war, politics, fashion,
the press.
Jimmy Savile, he's written
about not so long ago,
and the trappings of fame.
You've heard that he's the
author of numerous novels, five
novels, two works of
nonfiction, and many awards.
But I want to say a little
bit about how he writes,
not just what he writes about.
There are a couple
of things I've
heard you say recently that made
me think of your own writing.
One is that the world is
vastly under-described,
and the other is to do
with beauty of thought.
That's not something that is
much introduced in journalism
these days, but it's
something that is very
particular the way Andy writes.
I mean, he's an
incredible investigator,
you'll see from this book,
like an old fashioned gumshoe
or detective.
Incredibly good at
marshaling the information
he gathers also, which is rare.
But as well as
that, I think there
are some incredible
and incredibly elegant,
frightening, if anything,
ideas in this book that
will alter your mind, perhaps,
even without the need for some
of the illegal drugs available
on the internet, which there
are also some instructions
about in here.
So please do read it.
And I know you each have a copy.
We'll talk a little
bit about it first.
There are three essays in
the book, originally written
for the "London
Review of Books,"
very long pieces-- well,
two very long pieces,
one about Julian Assange, as you
heard, one about Craig Wright,
also known as Satoshi Nakamoto,
who is the founder of the cyber
currency Bitcoin.
And one about the
possibilities of inventing
a self over the internet.
And Andrew will talk a
little bit about that.
I mean, just to begin with,
these are linked pieces.
Can you talk a
little bit about how
they evolved from each
other, or how they
were conceived at the start?
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Funnily
enough, the one that
wasn't part of an invitation--
I was invited by Julian
Assange and his representatives
to help him write his memoir.
That's a whole story in itself.
And I was approached by Craig
Wright, the purported inventor
of Bitcoin much later, not
to help him write a book,
but to be the subject of
a book that I might write.
So those two were, as it
were, offered up to me.
I suppose offered
up not innocently,
because I had
already established
an interest in questions of
selfhood and disappearance
in the age of the internet.
The middle story, though,
was what really started them.
I'd been carrying it in my head
for quite a long time, I think
for possibly, 12 or 13 years,
a notion that I would like
to write an extended
nonfiction piece where I took
the name of a dead child,
and fashioned a life
based on that name.
Doing effectively, what
the Metropolitan Police had
famously or infamously
done in London
for many years, which
was to build legends
around these names they'd
found in graveyards.
And using those
names, those legends,
those false identities, they
would infiltrate left wing
groups around the country.
And they went a bit far, some
of those officers, in the sense
that they lived a
wholly second life.
Married people, had children in
their second life whilst going
home, if you like, to
their first identity.
So I was interested
in all of that.
And I felt that that
story, if I could write it,
would tell you
something about a way
of having a self,
multiple selves possibly,
in the age of internet.
And that really was just
stating and growing in me
for a long time even before
I began the Assange project.
But once I wrote
the Assange story,
I knew that it was inevitable.
I would write the life
of Ronnie Pinn, the story
of a invented identity.
And that led-- because Bitcoin
comes up in that story--
I was alert to Bitcoin when
I finished the Ronnie Pinn.
And it was at that point that
these Los Angeles lawyers
contacted me with the idea
that I might be furnished
with all the details of
this man, Craig Wright, who
claimed to be Satoshi Nakamoto.
GABY WOOD: And that
was just a coincidence.
I mean, you were
using Bitcoin currency
in order to buy things on
the internet as Ronnie Pinn.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Yes.
GABY WOOD: But then
they approached you,
they had no idea
you'd been doing that.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: No, they didn't.
I mean, they felt, from
reading novels of mine,
and nonfiction pieces,
that I might be
the right person for the job.
I'm always a bit
curious as to why
they think I'm the right
person for those jobs.
Because I have to
say, especially here
in the environs at Google--
I mean, I'm not
a natural techie.
I'm not ultra-experienced
in these matters.
I had to really make a journey.
You often do, as you
know, as a writer
of fiction and nonfiction,
you sort of disappear
into the world beyond
your ignorance,
if you know what I mean.
You start off-- often the
best position, in fact,
to be starting off is
to know very little.
I knew very little
about cryptocurrency
when I met Craig Wright.
By the end, I think, I'd been
living with it for the best
part of a year, and was inside
the whole eccentric sort
of worlds within
worlds that exist.
I'm sure many of the listeners
will know about that world.
And its very strange.
Its almost like a
simulacrum of a society,
a sort of society going
slightly wrong, I would argue.
GABY WOOD: Yeah.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: It's unstable.
And they're very unstable
about each other.
It's not a natural
harmonious world
of learning and investigation,
the world of computer science.
Sometimes-- certainly, when
it came to Craig Wright
and the question of Satoshi--
it was a giant sort of
school playground for me.
GABY WOOD: Yeah.
Well, Google comes up in
that story, doesn't it?
Because there's a
suggestion-- there's
a very interesting distinction
between the currency
and the idea for the currency.
You know, could he be
prosecuted, for instance,
if guns were bought
with his currency?
Which you do as Ronnie
Pinn, incidentally.
Then could he be prosecuted?
But in fact, what was suggested
was that what could be sold
was the intellectual property,
which was the idea behind it.
And perhaps that would
be sold even to Google.
I mean, the lawyer has
an idea about that.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Well, the
men in black, as I call them,
which was the two, the
one from Vancouver,
and the other man from Australia
who were joining forces
to repackage the purported
Satoshi's patents
and sell them to, as it
were, Google was certainly
in the frame at one point,
and being shown this material.
And the figures were
very high, because you
were talking about pretty
advanced and quite excellent
patents, moving towards AI,
and developments linking
the blockchain to developments
in artificial intelligence
in a way that was pretty
pucker, and certainly fresh.
And those patents-- many of
them have been established,
or registered, anyway.
And so there was big
money being suggested.
And the muckiness of
Craig Wright's world,
and his tax affairs, and the
question of prosecutions,
which I have to say, I always
thought were ludicrous.
I mean, to prosecute the people
who administer crypto currency
because it's used for
illicit purposes would
be a bit like prosecuting
the Bank of England
because there was a
suitcase of tenners
found at King's Cross that were
going to be used to buy drugs.
I mean, it's ludicrous.
The currency is just a thing.
GABY WOOD: Well, but it's
indicative of the fear.
People don't really
know what this is.
How would the law respond
to something so new?
ANDREW O'HAGAN: I think there's
a lot of fear in that way.
I mean, I get a lot
of correspondence,
and a lot of questions
coming from people who--
they're frightened
of cryptocurrency.
I mean, people who have
mortgages, that is to say,
most people who have mortgages
and who have pensions, and who
pay into funds of various
sorts, and insurances,
they worry that
the thing they've
been doing all their life is, as
it were, bogus or meaningless.
And of course it is.
[LAUGHTER]
And that's very hard
to take, if you've
been paying into a
pension for 40 years,
to suddenly to
realize that it's just
a kind of a piece
of mathematics.
And so what one of the things
that cryptocurrency does,
I think, is that makes
that absolutely explicit.
When you get into
talking about currency,
and you realize that in
certain parts of civilizations
in the past, people used
shells, or they used feathers,
or we use pieces of paper
with the Queen's face stamped
on them.
It's all ludicrous.
It's as ludicrous, or no
less so than lines of code,
you might argue.
But lines of code--
which, of course, is what all
our bank accounts are now--
cause people to have a
nervous breakdown, as opposed
to a suitcase of tenners,
which seems to mean something.
I, mean--
GABY WOOD: Yeah,
because it's material
ANDREW O'HAGAN: --a child's eyes
would widen if you handed them
a bunch of 50 pound notes.
If you said oh, I've just
installed on your computer, 20
Bitcoin, they might
go, well, show me
what I can do with that.
But increasingly, of course--
GABY WOOD: Well,
though, the kids would--
ANDREW O'HAGAN: --generation--
GABY WOOD: --be more likely to--
ANDREW O'HAGAN: --they
are much more likely.
GABY WOOD: --to appreciate it.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: They
just need to check
today's value of one
Bitcoin, and they know
that you were enriching them.
But obviously, for
those of us who
grew up before digital
currency, we have trouble.
And some people are
frightened of it.
But I don't see why.
Now that I've worked with it,
I think it's wholly logical.
GABY WOOD: Well, it is
actually sort of one
of these ideas that shows
you what you've been living
with all along, I supposed.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Yeah, it's sort
of turns it up to the light
that it's always been a
sort of invented thing.
Money is a bit of a--
GABY WOOD: Mirage.
ANDREW O'HAGAN:
--and the question
of value isn't an actual, real,
touchable thing in the way
that I think we
imagine it is when
we see a stack of
paper in our wallet,
we think, well,
that's what I'm worth.
GABY WOOD: Yeah.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: The
question of what
you're worth is actually
behind all this.
GABY WOOD: Well, exactly.
That's what [INAUDIBLE] coming
to, the idea of being human.
But do you want to
talk a little bit
about Assange, how you found
him to be in the first place?
I'm sure you're very
interested in how he was.
I mean, right at
the beginning, you
seem to have been
quite convinced
that he was a courageous
person, regardless
of how he was in his habits.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: I was very
struck by the position
he was in when I
first met him, that
is to say a man wearing
an electronic ankle
bracelet, effectively under
house arrest in Ellingham
Hall, a large country house
outside Bungay, of all places,
in Norfolk.
And I was invited there
to come and meet him.
And I had followed
the Wikileaks case,
if you like, pretty
much from the beginning.
I was fascinated by
what they were doing.
I've always been fascinated
by both individuals
and institutions and
publications that speak truth
to power in that way,
and seek to undermine
the secret bonds that can
exist between governments
and the media, or the media and
certain individuals in society,
or big money issues and causes,
and the flow of information.
The relationship between
marketing and publicity
and morality has
always interested me.
So I thought there
it is, there's
an organization,
finally, that is not
allowing any of
these relationships
to be taken for granted.
And the Afghan war
logs made it clear
that there had been a
rather corrupt relationship
between the Ministry of
Defense, for example,
or American military
authorities and news gatherers.
The civilian casualties
after certain military raids
by the Americans
and the UK forces
were being actually
misrepresented.
Or sometimes, if a rocket
was fired into a building,
you would see an actual log
that was published by Wikileaks
that 35 people had died in that
attack as collateral damage,
or civilian casualties.
That was reported in the
actual contemporaneous log
by a military officer.
But then when you looked
at the news reports,
you saw that it
said three had died.
And that was happening
all the time.
And so I thought that was
a wonderful contribution.
That's just one example.
They were doing
enormously good work,
and still are certain
quarters, trying
to reveal how these
relationships are corrupt,
and the information
is not to be trusted,
and that bonds of secrecy
are, to some extent,
self-serving for
those individuals.
So that was the good news.
GABY WOOD: Yeah.
And then you were presented
with the individual [INAUDIBLE]..
ANDREW O'HAGAN: And
then it becomes not just
about an organization
doing good work,
or struggling to introduce a
new idea of honesty, truth,
and progress into
society, but it comes down
to a series of individuals.
And the main individual, of
course, was Julian Assange.
I got on very well with
him personally at the time.
I find him to be quite brave.
And he was in a situation
of threat at that time.
The Americans had declared that
they wished to prosecute him
under the Espionage Act.
There were other much
less clear threats to him.
There was the Swedish rape
allegations, for example.
GABY WOOD: Well, what was
your position on that?
I mean, so you're
approaching this man.
He's got on one hand,
he's courageous,
he's exposing the US government.
On the other hand, several
women are accusing him of rape.
I mean, you're
going into his den.
How do you feel about
that [INAUDIBLE]??
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Well,
I wanted them always
to be two separate issues.
They are two separate issues.
If, as it were--
let's just deal on a
fictitious possible executive
editor at a Boston newspaper.
If he or she was
accused of rape,
and you were making an
assessment of their work
at the Boston newspaper, they
would be two separate things.
What's the newspaper doing, what
happened in his private life?
But Assange himself created
a disastrous conflation
between the two, in my opinion.
And I was with him for really,
the best part of a year.
When he moved out
of Ellingham Hall
into the Ecuadorian
embassy, I thought
that was a very ethically
dodgy move as well,
to seek asylum
with a nation that
has no great record on
freedom of expression.
But that's a whole other issue.
That's where he chose to go.
He was there.
I used to see him there.
And at that point,
that conflation
I'm talking about between
the threat from the Americans
to close him down--
that's a First Amendment issue.
He published the
same material that
was published by
"The New York Times"
and by "The Guardian,"
and by "Der Spiegel."
And if you're going to
prosecute Julian Assange--
and I'd even say that today-- if
you're going to prosecute him,
you need to prosecute them.
And of course, none of
them should be prosecuted.
They did the work of
old-fashioned, truth-telling,
campaigning journalism,
speaking truth to power.
And no matter how unsavory
or how unattractive
a defender of liberty Julian
Assange or any of them are,
I would stick up for the right
to do the work that they've
been doing.
You've been asking
about this conflation.
Suddenly, that need
to represent and fight
for truth was blended in
his account of his situation
with the Swedish allegations.
Even the other day, I saw
him appearing in the balcony
with his fist raised at when
the Swedish allegations had
been dropped.
Now that was not a
victory for liberty.
He did not escape from
a false accusation.
He simply didn't allow
himself to be questioned.
Now he might have
come on to the balcony
and explained that
there had been
a disastrous misunderstanding.
He could have expressed
empathy with the two
women who felt that they
had to make that accusation.
He could have done
a number of things.
But to position himself as
the victim in that case,
and conflate it
in his description
of his situation
of being in forced
detention-- he's not
in forced detention.
He could walk out today.
And it's a bit like a child who
goes la, la, la, la and hopes
that the truth won't penetrate.
And that's what I found to
be true again and again,
is that he was obfuscating and
dissembling to such an extent,
that if you're writing a book
with a person lying to you,
and it's a memoir, that's
incredibly hazardous.
And that's the position
I find myself in.
GABY WOOD: So interesting,
because actually,
the whole book is about lies,
different kinds of lies,
lies that you tell
yourself, lies
that people tell each other.
Fiction-- is it a lie?
What kinds of invention?
And in that case,
you can understand
that he has created
a paranoid scenario,
or at least he's entered
and perhaps created
exaggerations of that.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: I
mean, I always felt,
and I still feel that
for any of us, if there's
an accusation of that sort, you
have to go and clear your name.
That's not just a
sort of empty phrase.
Clearing your name is a thing.
I feel sorry for Julian now,
because of his own actions,
and the pressures upon him, some
of which have been unnatural.
He's put himself in
a position of never
being able to clear
his name on that count.
I told him at the
time, regardless
of all the threats of
extradition, all the threats--
and I know that's easy for us
to say, but if you're brave,
you're brave.
You stand up for
what you published,
and you go and face whatever
these terrifying and awful
threats are.
And if he had done
that, the entire world
community of freedom
fighters and people
who believed in the First
Amendment in the United States,
people who believed in
freedom of expression,
would have come around
him and supported him.
He would have been
the hero of the age
in freedom of expression terms.
Instead of which, he's left
with this absolutely unanswered
series of questions
about what happened
with the Swedish girls.
And he's conflated it with
a precarious situation
he has in relation to
the American threat.
And it's never going to be
solved unless he individually
takes each issue one at a
time, and deals with them.
And at the time, I kept
saying appearing in America
before these people with their
bogus and unconstitutional
attempt to take
him down or silence
him would have made him a
great exemplar and a great hero
in this area.
And I never understood
why he didn't do that.
GABY WOOD: Yeah, it's
interesting that he didn't.
I mean, let's talk about lying
generally, as a sort of--
there's an idea that
comes up in here
about lying as a
kind of signature.
I mean, if you're a writer,
or if you're a coder,
it doesn't really matter.
You're kind of writing
or doing as only you can,
and so lying is your
medium in some way.
I mean, the Ronnie
Pinn story is that.
You've invented somebody.
He is a lie.
You're entering a fiction.
I mean, it's a
nonfiction account.
But essentially, it's a sort
of live version of what you
do when you're writing a novel.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Absolutely.
And I think as somebody
who's spent all my career now
writing fiction and
nonfiction, and walking
the rather unstable borders
sometimes between the two--
I mean, I've always been
interested in the relationship
between what is imagined
and what is real,
or what is fiction and
what is journalism.
And the relationships
between all of them
have always been
slightly unstable for me,
and I've been excited by that.
And now I've got to
the position where
the whole idea of the
fictional nature of the times
has become a fascinating
subject to me.
You only need to use
the words Donald Trump
and you begin to see that the
stable relationship that you
might wish to assume was reality
is quite a big assumption now.
GABY WOOD: Yeah.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: In
the era of fake news,
and the era of a purported
leader of the free world
who can use his handheld
device to promulgate lies,
and fictions, and
false statements,
and question the
number of people
who were there in a
photographable place,
watching his inauguration.
Can actually argue with
the photographic evidence
from his own-- not
through public relations,
not through the press briefing,
not through interviews
he might give-- but through
his own direct contact
with an audience of millions.
And that is an aspect of
the world we're living in.
And fiction writers
and nonfiction writers
might take an interest in that.
I can't understand
how anybody would
find that sort of unremarkable.
GABY WOOD: Yeah.
No, extraordinary.
But also, the idea that people
withhold information just
in daily life.
That's a truth.
That's a fact.
And but it's also a fiction.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Yeah.
GABY WOOD: How about this idea
of men who are not really men?
I mean, Ronnie Pinn
is not really a man,
because he literally
does not exist.
But there's also Craig
Wright's oddness.
Assange, also, you felt was
sort possibly on the spectrum.
I mean, it must
have made you ask--
I mean, it's clear
that it made you ask
what it is that makes us human.
I mean, two men, the
two real men, so-called,
have kind of lost
something of their humanity
through their circumstances.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: I think it's
an interesting question, that.
Because I did ask myself a lot
with those particular guys,
if there wasn't
something alarmingly
arrested in each case.
And I have to say that so many
of the people that I worked
with in relation to the
cryptocurrency question
and in relation
to Wikileaks were
either on the spectrum
by their own admission,
or had some sense of arrested
development, that they were
stuck in a kind of childhood
fantasia about rectitude,
and about being vindicated.
The amazing thing about Assange
in particular was that--
I mean, his pride was
of a childish sort.
I mean, he's in
the embassy today.
I mean, he could
come out, and he
would be taken to Paddington
Green police station
and booked for jumping bail.
Booked.
That's it.
I mean, he wouldn't go
to jail for decades.
He probably wouldn't
go to jail at all.
Then after a few days,
and the paying of a fine,
he'd be able to get on a
plane and go somewhere.
But he, in a sense,
he's under conditions
of suspended animation
that he's addicted to.
That there's a fantasy
of heroism going on,
that I'm under arrest.
I'm being silenced.
I'm being imprisoned.
And he always spoke
in that way to me.
He hated the idea of conceding
to normal circumstances,
or in any sense,
showing weakness.
His big obsession was weakness.
He was always saying to me--
if I'd say, well, maybe
you were wrong about that.
And we can say there was
no question of admitting
that I was wrong about that.
There was no question of
showing any self-deprecation.
At one point in the
story, I say that I
tried to give him a crash
course in self-deprecation.
The idea that you could
tell a joke against yourself
is completely foreign to him.
It's the cornerstone of good
humor and wit and friendship,
that you can take the piss
out of your own supposedly
unassailable position.
But he wanted the illusion
of unassailability,
even in his own memoir.
I did say to him
one day, do you need
to make yourself the hero of
absolutely every anecdote?
Is there any possibility
that you were ludicrous?
Because of course, if you
know anything about writing,
you know that it's not just
a piece of self-advertising,
or a piece of PR.
All great stories
involve a certain amount
of humorous failure,
and self-failure,
and misapplication,
and mis-naming.
There was none of that allowed.
And I got the sense
very early that whatever
those boiling contradictions
of his childhood were,
they had created
an absolute need
for international
vindication every day.
And that's incredible to me.
GABY WOOD: Yeah.
ANDREW O'HAGAN:
Fascinating, though.
GABY WOOD: Yeah.
No, it's extraordinary.
This idea of a ghost--
I mean, the first essay
is called "Ghosting."
But also, I suppose that
Ronnie Pinn is a kind of ghost,
because he's based
on a dead person.
I mean, you haven't
quite resurrected him,
because you've
invented a new person.
The book is partly about
the traces we leave behind,
or it's possible for a fictional
person to leave lots of traces,
but for a real person
to leave no traces.
Or Craig Wright wipes
out his digital history
or the traces of himself.
So it is linked to this
idea of memory, I suppose.
But it's mainly very specific
to the era in which we live now,
that the idea of
technology as memory,
or technology as a ghost.
That sort of--
ANDREW O'HAGAN: I
mean, technology
has become the
ghostifying thing for me
in that the ghostifying thing--
GABY WOOD: Defying?
ANDREW O'HAGAN: No, it
makes you sort of ghostly.
It makes all of us--
we're ghosting our--
I mean, every time you add
something on Wikipedia,
what are you if not a ghost?
You're a ghostwriter.
We're all ghostwriters now.
And as it happens,
I've always believed
that novelists and
poets are ghostwriters.
You're always
ghostwriting for somebody.
If you're inventing a
character, and you're
writing in the first person, as
many novelists do very often,
one of the things you
are is a ghostwriter.
GABY WOOD: Because your
character is the writer?
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Yes.
And you're making it
for somebody else.
I mean, I've always
been interested
in that relationship.
I mean, I know it's got
a commercial definition,
and that people ghostwrite
things [INAUDIBLE]..
We get that.
But the most interesting form
of ghostwriting, I think,
is the sense of
throwing your voice,
of haunting houses that
you can't live in anymore.
Novelists do that all the time.
I'm haunted by the
books I've written,
as well as having been a ghost.
So those notions have
always interested me.
My first book was
called "The Missing."
I was interested in the
disappearance of women--
you'll remember, Gaby, that
some of the investigations I
was doing at that
time were about women
who were murdered by
Fred and Rosemary West
in Gloucestershire, and who
were never reported as missing.
They were ghosts.
And the idea that they could
have lived in the world,
and had relationships,
and gone to schools,
and had GPs and siblings,
but nobody reported them
as missing.
They just sort of vaporized.
And that was a new
thing in society.
And that was slightly
pre-internet, wasn't it?
It was just really--
it wouldn't be accurate to
say it was pre-internet.
But it was before the
whole world of online
normality, if you can call it
that, this sort of customary,
you wake up in the morning,
and you turn on your computer.
It wasn't like that.
And none of that book was, as
it were, worked up from Google.
There was no search engine
then to check street names
and addresses, and histories,
and voters rolls. .
I mean, the way that
search engines have
changed the work that writers do
and journalists is incredible.
Because I remember, in order to
find out the various addresses
that girls had lived
at in the 1970s,
having to spend
months among the paper
electoral rolls at
the British Museum,
the British Library, as was--
GABY WOOD: In the
old days, yeah, yeah.
This means it was a round room.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Yeah,
having to go through them.
And poor [INAUDIBLE].
I mean, I think I damaged my
eyesight by the age of 26,
staring at those paper things.
But of course now, 192.com--
GABY WOOD: Straight away.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: You pay your
money, you got your credits,
you'll find anybody's address.
Not anybody's, but a fair
number of them very quickly.
And you'll find out where the
three previous addresses were.
It's a different world.
GABY WOOD: Yeah.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: So
the books were--
these stories, in a sense, are
continuing material for me,
and old topics revived, and
coming all the way around
in middle age to things that
interested me as a young man,
except the technology
has enriched and deepened
and estranged those
interests of mine.
GABY WOOD: Yeah, but
that's exactly what
I was going to ask you about.
Because there is
a point at which
you describe Wright as a
sort of missing person.
There's this line,
the complications
of being themselves
wipe them out.
That actually, these
people who are so--
I mean, we were
talking about being
on the spectrum-- that they
are missing, in some sense.
And so I was interested in how
your thoughts about missing
persons had evolved through
this, through thinking
about these people?
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Well,
it's interesting.
I mean, it has an absolute
direct, almost kind of--
there's a kind of
mirroring going
on between some of
those obsessions
I had about missing persons.
I had them in the book
called "The Missing."
But I also had
them in the novels,
that so many of the characters
in the novels earlier
were people who had lost
sight of their life.
They'd lost their selfhood
along the way somehow.
And now I was able to find out,
in relation to the Ronnie Pinn
story in this book, for example,
the middle story that we've
been talking about, that
when I was in that graveyard,
and choose that particular
dead child's name,
I saw that Ronald Pinn had
died 20 years old in 1980.
When I put the words Ronald
Pinn into your engine, no other,
the result was
precisely nothing.
There was nothing.
In relation to him, that
person [INAUDIBLE] nothing.
There was nothing
to bring you to him.
There was nothing to
tell you about his life.
There was no taste expressed.
There was no light.
There was nothing.
There was no memory.
By the end of the process of
my inventing a Ronald Pinn
based on him, there were
thousands and thousands
of the fake Ronnie Pinns.
So as the fake Ronnie Pinn's
footprint, in a sense,
completely outnumbered and
outclassed the original.
And it told you something
about what our life has become.
The original actual flesh
and blood Ronnie Pinn
had no footprint in the
world beyond perhaps,
in the memory of his
mother, who I later
found to be still alive.
And I end the piece
by going to visit.
And that's why I included
the real Ronnie Pinn.
Because I wanted
the reader to deal
with the ethical
difficulty, not only
of what I'd done in
order to tell the story
and reproduce the
police have done,
but also to think about what
it meant to have been a person.
Not just that I invented a guy
and put him into the dark net,
and made him buy
stuff, and drugs,
and guns and everything
else, and made
him exist in the sense of
having a false passport
and false driver's license.
But also, right
beside him, I was also
telling the thin story of
an actually existent person.
And I wanted that irony
to be right at the heart
of the reader's mind as
they were reading the story.
GABY WOOD: Yeah.
Because the question
does crop up,
of course, why you
needed to do that,
why you needed to take
a once real person,
or why you couldn't
just make up a name.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Yeah.
I mean, and that was the thing.
I could have made
life easy for myself
by just have inventing a name,
and a false birth certificate.
And I mean, there's all sorts
of ways to be a fake person,
trust me.
[LAUGHTER]
There's the question of
building a legend around us,
a real person was
a way of, as it
were, building up a
bank of integrity,
as the police called it.
If said to you, which
school did you go to?
You could say, well,
and you had it all.
GABY WOOD: When did you first
hear about that practice
of the police?
ANDREW O'HAGAN:
Quite a while ago,
just after it was
exposed, actually,
as having been a common
practice in the Met.
There was always
rumors about it.
And a police officer
told me back in the '90s
that this was happening.
And I thought, no.
But I always knew if it ever
could be made to emerge,
it would tell you an incredible
story about the times.
And I'm always
interested in stories
that, as it were, sort of
throw light on to the way
we live now.
I'm sort of fascinated by that.
I mean, Facebook
admits quite freely--
the numbers are
probably much higher
if they admit it freely--
that there are upwards of 78
million fake Facebook accounts.
GABY WOOD: Yeah.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: It's an
incredible statistic,
if you think about it.
That 78 million people
on the planet at least
have taken the trouble
to invent another self.
Now to whatever extent
they're using that self,
dwelling in that self,
embroidering that self,
using it to enter chat
rooms, using it just
as a way of looking in places
where they otherwise might be
too afraid to go, I don't know.
But it's an interesting part of
your potential experience now.
There was always
the double life.
We know about Oscar Wilde
and the double life.
But it was never, as it were,
a daily part of your activity
in the way that it can be now
because of the technology.
I think I'll just go
and be John for an hour.
GABY WOOD: Yeah.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: I think I'll go
and be Susan for five minutes.
I mean, the technology
allows that.
And I wanted to swim down into
that as far as I could go.
GABY WOOD: That's brilliant.
I mean, now in retrospect,
or having done all this work,
do you feel that
privacy is a right?
ANDREW O'HAGAN:
I've always felt it.
And I feel it more now.
GABY WOOD: Do you?
ANDREW O'HAGAN:
At the end, yeah.
I mean, I know there's a giant
question now, given that--
it was interesting,
Mark Zuckerberg,
who's obviously
younger than me, is
part of that generation feel
that privacy's completely
outmoded, that in a sense,
the wish for privacy
is a kind of misnomer.
Why would you wish for privacy
unless you were underhanded,
I think is
Zuckerberg's position.
And it certainly was
"Gawker's" position.
That every time a privacy
was exposed or corrupted,
"Gawker" cheered, and
thought, that's right.
That's one step closer
to the reality we want,
where nothing is private,
and nothing is secret.
But I, on the other
hand, would come in
and say that a raid on privacy
is a raid on selfhood itself.
The idea that there's no
respect for the private sphere,
a place where your consciousness
and its alterations,
your arguments with yourself,
that psychoanalytically,
the self's romance, it's
growth, and its backward slides,
and its relationship--
GABY WOOD: [INAUDIBLE]
done in public.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: --with
love and identity
is not about a public
manifestation always.
It's about an inward journey.
It's about an interiority.
I mean, we don't
have time today,
but we could talk
about how inarguably,
the whole of
literary fiction has
been an argument
about interiority
and how alterations
in what happens
to people inside themselves
impact on other people
and on the world.
I mean, that's Henry
James, is it not?
GABY WOOD: Absolutely, yeah.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: And
if you take that away,
and you just imagine that
if anybody's not telling you
something private, it's because
they're doing something wrong,
then you're playing
into the security state
in a way that will rue the day.
And now that we're in the
age of certain television
manufacturers, let's just say,
having a mechanism called fake
off.
Where your television,
when you switch it off,
isn't really off.
It's still recording
and still watching.
And that the security agencies
can gather that information
and use it.
Privacy, then-- including the
privacy that can exist between
two people--
what you say to your
girlfriend, or your husband,
or your boyfriend
might well be a matter
that is all the deeper and
all the more enjoyable,
to put it at its most
basic, because it's private,
because nobody
else knows that you
feel exactly this at this
moment, and that you did this.
If it's all out there in
some "Gawker" universe,
then I think it's a degradation
of human experience,
I have to say.
GABY WOOD: Yeah, I feel that,
even about teenagers saying,
love you in a text message.
[LAUGHTER]
GABY WOOD: We should probably
let you ask some questions
if you'd like.
And if so, do step up
to the David Lynch mike
that we have here ready
to scramble your speech.
We can carry on
talking [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: So can you hear me?
Is that all right?
ANDREW O'HAGAN: I can, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So you just all on that point
where it seems inevitably
we're going to a world where
we don't have privacy anymore,
what are your thoughts on that?
And in your experience
speaking to people
like Craig Wright
or Julian Assange,
what role we're going
to play in that,
and what role
these other powers,
and these people
are going to play
in deciding how that turns out?
GABY WOOD: When you say we, do
you mean the general public,
or do you mean, you, Google?
AUDIENCE: I'd say the
general public, no.
I very much mean
the general public.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Thank you.
Well, I think it's
going to be one
of the big challenges
for this generation,
and for coming
generations is trying
to find a code of
decency, and, as it were,
a philosophical set of thoughts
about how we as human beings
exist in relation
to our devices.
There's going to
be a giant new era.
I'm not just talking about
artificial intelligence.
I'm talking about
even our relationship
with a search engine.
What is that engine
in our epistemology?
What is it in our
sense of who we are,
and how we relate to history
and the present, and in relation
to the known and the unknown,
in relation to privacy,
and the told?
It's not-- | don't think we're
more than 10 minutes away
from the point where that will
be one of the things we do
at university is to try and
work out what a relationship is
as individuals with an
encoded identity, with a DNA.
And is that a paramount
thing in the future?
Or are we all simply part
of a neural network, where
we're hardwired into
a neural network where
we have a certain force,
perhaps, a certain brightness.
We shine a certain light for a
short period, and then go out.
But we don't actually have a
private universal narrative
that we have sovereignty over.
The question of
sovereignty of self
in the age of the
internet, will be, I think,
one of the great challenges
for writers, thinkers,
practitioners,
individuals, technologists
the day after tomorrow.
As for those
individuals that you've
mentioned that I've
worked with, they
will be remembered as people
who made a contribution to this,
I'm sure.
One of the reasons I was so
drawn to sticking with them,
even through sometimes quite
harrowing circumstances,
because I really
believed that they
were important
fighters in that debate
that I've described as
both coming and happening.
They wouldn't be
victorious, necessarily.
Neither of those men,
at least, up to today,
are having a triumphant time.
Craig Wright, in the end, failed
to consolidate his position
as Satoshi Nakamoto.
He failed his own
paternity test in public.
Although I personally
always believed
that he was certainly there
at the foundation of Bitcoin,
and that his attachment
to the technology,
his attachment to the timeline,
and his being in possession
of the codes--
it was too much evidence.
So the mask had--
as it were-- eaten so
deeply into his face
that he couldn't take it off
is one way of putting it.
The Satoshi mask-- and
not just into his face,
but I presume, into
others that he worked
with on that original software.
Assange is a different story.
But he too will be an
important figure, I think,
when we come to look at
what is the relationship
between an individual
and the state.
That will be-- just as
we talk with John Wilkes,
I think, as somebody who
opened up the question of what
was liberty.
And we're still asking
what is liberty?
But you need to ask
the question every day.
Because the meaning changes
every day in relation to what's
in front of it.
And what's in front
of it at the moment
is a series of powers
within the machine that
will change the
nature of the law,
to say nothing of morality.
So I think we're in
for exciting times.
But we're in the
foothills at the moment.
I mean, we don't even have
a generally agreed code
of decency for the
internet at the moment.
And that sounds like the
beginnings of an argument
for censorship, and it's not.
I mean, I'm not into censoring
films, or censoring television.
But I generally believe in
the board of certification,
and I generally believe
in the watershed.
Because I've got a
13-year-old and I
don't want her to be
frightened going to bed.
It doesn't mean I
want censorship.
It's the same with the internet.
We need to get a
bit sophisticated,
I think, in our
politics about it.
Because it's a bit kind of
you're either for everything
or you're for censorship.
And there's got to be
something-- there's
so much thinking to be done.
It's not going to be
done by me, clearly.
It's done by people
cleverer than I, I hope.
I hope it will be done.
GABY WOOD: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank you.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Thank you.
GABY WOOD: Is there
another question?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned how you
invented an individual based
on this young man
that had died before.
How did you approach the
ethical questions around this?
Does this young man have
some kind of right of privacy
after his death?
And are you altering
his memory without him
being able to consent?
ANDREW O'HAGAN: That's an
interesting core question
about that story for me.
Believe me, I was well
aware of it at the time.
And you don't go into writing
a story like that blind.
I mean, in a sense, the
story's about that question.
And I believe as
a writer, your job
isn't to just
solve all the maths
and tell the reader how clever
you are as a mathematician,
morally or otherwise.
Your job is just to provide the
arithmetic in the right way,
and in the right
order and walk away.
And I believe that
there was only one
way to tell that story of the
ethical nightmare of stealing
dead children's names, and
creating false identities,
as our police force was doing.
The only way to tell
that was to do it.
To really get inside
how they did it,
and what it meant, and
did it have an effect--
to go back to your question-- on
one's sense of the real person.
Another question
that comes with it
is do we own the story
of our own lives?
Do you own your story?
Do you, Gaby, own yours?
Does anybody in the
audience or watching
actually have ownership rights
on what happens to them?
Because you might
say it doesn't really
belong to oneself at all,
it belongs to the world.
Where I was born and what
happened, and what I did
and what was did to me
is a possession of mine.
Is the story of my
children my possession?
I know we behave as if it is.
Because if it's a corruption
of some personal ownership.
But ultimately, it
belongs to history,
and it belongs to the world,
and it belongs to writing.
That's my argument.
But there's a more
popular, I think,
ethical position, which is that
Ronnie Pinn's mother, as it
were, owns his memory now.
And that it was a
corruption of his memory
to take him and attach these
details to somebody else.
Again, I would argue
that I wanted the reader
to go on asking themselves
about that ethical difficulty
long after the
story was finished.
My job, in a sense, would
be done if that happened.
For my own part,
I certainly felt
it was important to tell the
actual story of the true Ronnie
Pinn as part of my story so
as not to dodge the bullet.
And in a sense, your
question suggests
that I might have taken
him away from reality.
I think I gave him a
reality that he didn't
have by recording him, finally.
Because now, the real
Ronnie Pinn story
is actually part of what we can
say about that young man who
lived and died in 1980.
But I agree with you.
It's an ethical conundrum.
That's why I wrote it.
A lot of stories are.
GABY WOOD: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: On my
way back to office,
I was listening to Malcolm
Gladwell's recent podcast.
So he is explaining
about a CIA informant,
and asked the ethical
question of the one side,
we have the need
for need to know,
and the other side that
is personal safety.
I mean, when you go
into these secret lives,
you're going to get entangled
into very serious stuff,
espionage, national security,
and things like that.
Do you have an
experience of that kind?
Or in that case, how do you--
you might have to withhold some
information from the public.
Or do you decide that?
From your discussion
about the Wikileaks,
and they felt that you wanted
to have more information given
to the public.
So [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Well, that
is actually-- thank you
for that question--
it was actually
core to the whole Wikileaks
experience over the war logs,
was that Wikileaks were very
keen to dump that material
onto the internet pretty fast.
And indeed they did.
There was a question
from some quarters,
including some of
the public publishing
partners, "The
Guardian" and so on,
about whether the material
should be redacted
before appearing in public.
And there's a strong argument
for redaction in that case,
as implicit in your question.
Because sometimes,
informants will be named.
And you might be condemning
them to death, actually,
by just dumping that material
straight onto the net.
That was a strong argument
in the Wikileaks case.
Now they've resisted
it, sometimes clumsily,
sometimes with good argument.
But it was debatable.
But from my
perspective, redaction
would always be necessary.
Redactions are something a
bit of an incendiary word.
Again, it's like censorship.
You're not censoring
something because you
can't face the truth.
You're editing it so as
to protect the innocent.
And we do that every
day in writing.
We do it every
day in journalism,
we do it every day in
software production.
You don't have such a
respect for the truth
as if the truth is of
this of clear flowing
river of excellence.
It's a muddy thing, full
of branches and roots,
and made up stuff,
and old prams,
and stuff that was never true,
but people think it's true.
I mean, the truth is a
capacious mess of a thing.
And so the idea of just dumping
the truth on the internet
is always going to be
questionable to me.
I believe in editing.
I believe in publishing.
I believe in the judgments
that come with selection,
with scholarship.
And I was always trying to push
Wikileaks towards scholarship,
towards the publisher vessel,
and to proper academics taking
the material from each region,
and spending years filtering,
collating, examining,
annotating.
Because that is a thing.
That's a whole industry,
and it matters in human life
to carefully--
even as journalists-- to
carefully, with a legal eye,
and also with an eye for
protecting individuals,
even if they don't hold
your political views.
Perhaps even especially
if they don't
hold your political views,
you must protect them
against savagery that
might come their way
from your careless
exposure of them.
That was a big issue,
and it continues
to be a big issue
when you're dealing
with secret information, or
formerly secret information.
It was there-- we won't
go into it today--
but it was there in the Edward
Snowden case with the NSA.
He was altogether a
much more cognizant,
I think, of the problems
and the deeper issues
to do with safety and security.
I think it's naive and
childish just to suggest
that all security is bogus.
I want to say grow
up to those people.
There are threats against us.
There are lunatics in the world.
And there are people with
strong political arguments
who behave like
lunatics as well.
But we must defend
ourselves against them,
and protect our
children, our people.
And that will involve a certain
amount of secrecy and sharing
of information in a careful way.
It doesn't make one a
right-winger to recognize that.
I think it should be recognized.
At the same time, I'm
all for breaking down
those false and
corrupt links that
can exist between governments,
moneyed individuals,
and ideologues and so on,
which is what Wikileaks started
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Thank you.
GABY WOOD: Good
question, thank you.
Is there another one?
We have a bit more
time if you want.
If not, actually,
I want to ask you
something about your own
position in all of this.
Because at one point, you
say that pleasing people
is a vice and a virtue.
I can't remember
which way around.
Virtue as a man and a vice as
a journalist, or the other way
around.
The other way around.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Yeah.
GABY WOOD: And there's another
point at which someone wants
a cigar-- must be Assange--
and you give it to him.
There's just one line, he wanted
a cigar, and I gave him one.
I thought, wow, he's got cigars
just lying around his house.
This is a perfect--
who knew that this
was the job of a reporter?
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Just keep
a stash, just in case.
You never know when
the Castros might
arrive at the door wanting
a cup of tea and a cigar.
GABY WOOD: Exactly.
So I mean, how do you
position yourself,
or are your concerns
about reporting
on some of this tricky
material as a sort of voyeur
or whatever you want
to call yourself?
ANDREW O'HAGAN: I think that
the reporter should always,
at least in my book, be
ready to put themselves
through the mill a bit.
GABY WOOD: In what way?
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Well, it
doesn't mean necessarily
be digging in your elbows
under the barbed wire,
sort of, at the war front.
But it sometimes does mean that.
It means putting yourself
at risk to get the truth.
It means exposing yourself
to a certain amount
of psychological difficulty.
It means walking in the rain.
It means walking away
from your comforts.
It means not sitting at
home working on your novel,
but actually-- which is
an important activity
if you a novelist.
But sometimes putting
on your sneakers
and going out into
inclement situations
in order to know what's
happening, in order
to bring back the moral
news to your desk.
I just think it's worth it.
It sometimes got to be done.
But I don't think that the
writer in that situation
should set him or herself
up as well as the morally
resplendent person.
I mean, you sometimes see
essayists and writers who
think of themselves that way.
Good luck to them.
And maybe they are morally
resplendent in every way.
I never thought that
was the writer's job.
I believe the Janet
Malcolm position,
as expressed in "The
Journalist and the Murderer,"
a famous piece for "The New
Yorker," where she realized
that there is a sort of--
it's almost like an acting
job, sometimes, being a writer.
Each one requires you to sort
of take a position in the room.
Quite often, you fade
into the wallpaper,
and that's a performance too,
if you're quite vivacious,
and you quite like people,
and you're quite sociable.
Sometimes just not
speaking is a performance.
And that's what I meant when
I said pleasing people can
be a vice and a virtue.
But sometimes, I'm just focusing
on the reader being my friend,
not the people in the
room being my friend.
I don't owe a debt
of friendship to any
of the subjects in this book.
I mean, I might have felt some
residual friendship for them,
and some loyalty, actually.
They may not see it that
way, but there was a lot.
It took me a long time
to write these stories,
and I held much
out of the frame,
because it was
irrelevant to my purpose.
So there was loyalty, and
continually so, I think.
What there is, is the
sense that you have
to do the job for the reader.
And Joseph Mitchell, that
great other "New Yorker" writer
taught us that you just
have to disappear slightly
into the miasma of
the thing that's
difficult to
describe, and somehow,
let it happen to you too.
GABY WOOD: Yeah,
that's a nice idea.
The two things that Craig
Wright asked you not
to say about his personal
life, you withheld them?
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Yes.
Yes, I did.
And again, there are the
great warriors for truth
who will say, why
did you compromise
by not mentioning them?
But it was a bit like
our friend's question
before about security.
Those two individual points
he asked me to hold back on,
had I not held back on them,
could have resulted in harm
to two sets of individuals.
And I made a very straight
and clear in my mind
decision to leave
out that material.
It was good material, too.
[LAUGHTER]
GABY WOOD: Well, so supposing
he didn't realize it
would have caused harm, and he
didn't ask you to withhold it,
but you realized that
they would of caused harm,
and you decided.
Would you then have decided
to withhold those things?
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Very
interesting, that.
I mean, I probably would have.
And one of the two--
I'm sorry this is
so tantalizing.
GABY WOOD: Yes, what is it?
ANDREW O'HAGAN: But
we're on camera.
But the problem was that I would
have made a judgment in favor
of withholding on
one of those counts,
because it involved, shall we
say, people more than averagely
innocent, young people.
GABY WOOD: OK.
ANDREW O'HAGAN:
In the other case,
I probably would have
gone ahead and told
that part of the
story, because I felt
it was a part of the story.
But it would possibly
have exposed that person
to serious doubts about
themselves, and danger.
They might have been a
danger to themselves,
and I just couldn't
take that risk.
No piece of journalism's
worth the loss of life,
I don't think.
And I certainly wasn't going
to be taking that risk.
GABY WOOD: So the question
whether all journalists
are aware of that as they go.
And in fact, Janet Malcolm--
I once interviewed
Janet Malcolm.
And I asked her
whether she ever felt
she had to protect people
from themselves, whether they
were telling too much, and
she wants to leave that out.
And she looked at me as
though I was completely mad.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Well, there are
moments sometimes when you're
sitting with a person,
and sometimes you've
been working with
them for months,
and they start to speak, and
something inside you cringes.
The tape recorder's on,
there's a notepad on your lap,
and they're saying something
so damaging to themselves
that you do think--
[SIGHS]
Because you know that it's
not your responsibility to
censor them, to stop them
from being who they are.
That would be false in
terms of what journalism is.
And yet, you're human, and you
have a relationship with them.
And they can't hear
how that sounds.
GABY WOOD: Yeah, exactly.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: And Janet
Malcolm would tell you--
I mean, she might
delight in such moments.
But she's probably
tougher than most.
And sometimes you delight in
it, because they're awful,
and you think, you're
now hanging, drawing,
and quartering yourself, as I
knew you were capable of doing.
But in other cases, you
think, no, no, you simply
are tin-eared when it comes
to how you are coming across.
And that thing I was telling
you about before, about people
having no ear for
self-deprecation,
no willingness to seek
themselves in a comic way.
And after many, many months
of that, you know the reader.
Because you become
an intelligencer
for the reader as a writer.
You're a kind of forwards
scout for their interpretation
sometimes.
And as a forward
scout, you're seeing
it coming sometimes,
and thinking, wow,
he's really going
to say that on tape?
And yeah, it happens.
GABY WOOD: In that sense, it's
is a bit like editing, though.
And you're a great
editor, where'
you're trying to imagine how
the reader will take this,
or you're saying to the
writer or the speaker,
is that really what
you want to say?
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Yeah.
I mean, and sometimes your job--
I mean,
non-controversially, if you
like, is to simply help the
person round to the place
where they can be clear
about what they're saying,
and what they did, and
why, and who was involved,
and what time.
Not everybody's a
born storyteller.
Some people give an awful
account of themselves,
just awful.
They give a very poor
eyewitness account
of what their life's
been like, most people.
If you asked most husbands to
give an account of what they
have been like as
a husband, they'd
give a terribly self-satisfied
one-sided account
of what it had been like.
GABY WOOD: Well, that's because
there are risks involved
in describing it differently.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: I'm sure.
But I mean, self-knowledge
isn't a given,
and neither is-- even if
you have self-knowledge--
neither is the ability to
then put that into sentences.
And so we're just talking
about interviewing here.
GABY WOOD: Yeah.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: The idea that
you interview a human being,
and they immediately
come flowing
with beautiful
sentences that are
totally accurate, and legally
secure is not the case.
People self invent, they
lie, they cut corners,
they edit, they
obfuscate, they dissemble.
They can't face it.
They wish they hadn't come.
But your job is to try
and swim through that
and find something true
and coherent, and hopefully
entertaining as well.
GABY WOOD: Well,
that's a great result.
And I think we're
going to end there.
Thank you all very
much for coming.
And thank you for watching.
And thank you especially,
Andy, for speaking to us.
ANDREW O'HAGAN: Thanks, Gaby.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]